all right so let's have a look at this
next question part c
evaluate the integral from naught to pi
onto of and then you can see this uh you
know particular integrand that's been
presented to you okay now
this is a heartbreakingly simple
question
i'm going to say it's even simpler than
the vector one that we were just looking
at not in terms of working but in terms
of the logic you needed to apply and it
low-key broke our hearts when we were
marking and students looked at this
question and they said oh it's an
integral it's got two like it's a
product in here i know what to do with a
product in an integrand i'm an extension
to student i'm going to go integration
by parts on this
and you know
hilarity ensued and you wasted a lot of
time okay this is not a question that
requires integration by parts it's one
of those classic situations where um
when you're holding a hammer everything
looks like a nail um even though you're
an extension 2 student in fact this
doesn't require anything much more than
extension 1 techniques this is a classic
reverse chain rule question if we go
ahead and write out what this integral
looks like so this is what we say part c
part c
integral from naught to pi on 2 of e to
the 1 plus cos x
sine x
dx i will do one thing to this and you
will see how simple it falls out as a
reverse chain rule question in fact i
think it's so simple simple simple
it's sinfully simple i think it's so
straightforward you don't even need to
introduce a separate and explicit
substitution i think you can all do it
in line let me prove it to you okay
i'm going to write this as naught to pi
on two of um
put this out the front
oops it is e make sure you take the
whole pie with you
negative negative sine x
e to the one plus cos x
dx
do you see it yet have i given enough
clues when saying it's just a reverse
chain rule question
is it not
an e to the f of x that you've got on
the right-hand side of the integrand and
an f a very straightforward f dash x
here on the left hand side right the
derivative of one plus cos x that one
just differentiates to zero but the cos
x differentiates to
minus sine so you're good to go just by
taking out that minus sign um you're
ready and the advantage of not having to
introduce an explicit substitution
is that i don't have to change the
variable or the boundaries rather of
integration i just leave them as naught
and pi on two so
here we go i'm ready to integrate and
watch this watch how heartbreakingly
simple it is that minus sign out the
front of the integral just stays put
what is this going to be well it's an e
to the power of something e to the power
of something when you differentiate it
it doesn't change right so therefore you
get e to the 1 plus cos
x it's
so
sadly simple maybe sinfully simple is
the right way to describe it so there
you go and all i need to do is just
evaluate here my upper and lower bounds
so just be careful with your minus sign
there uh i'm going to go
in fact that minus sign means i'm just
changing my order i can do my my
upper boundary sorry my lower boundary
first and then my upper boundary because
it's just you know the minus sign just
flips it all around so therefore i'm
going to do the 0 first 1 plus cos 0 and
then i'm going to minus the pi on two
one one plus cos of pi on two
okay um
e to the power of one plus cos zero cos
zero is one so therefore one plus one is
two and then on the end here cos of pi
on two is zero so this is just e to the
1 also known as e
and that's it
it was very straightforward if you knew
what you were doing
okay back into 3d vectors land what is
this question asking us
find the angle between
a
and b given you know you've got the xyz
components of these two vectors correct
to the nearest minute okay now just like
we saw a couple of brief questions ago
this is going to be the use of the dot
product just a slightly different one we
know that a dot product of zero gives us
two vectors at right angles these are
probably not at right angles just by
looking at the numbers and so we're
going to find out what that exact angle
is find the angle between them let's
have a go so part d
the first thing i'm going to do just so
that i don't have to keep on referring
to the papers i'm just going to write
down the two vectors in question so a is
going to be 2
i minus 3
j plus 5 k
and then b
is designated by 5i
plus 3j
minus 7k all right now for the next part
right everyone likes to write this a
slightly different way but i'm just
going to show you the way that i like to
think about it i always go back to the
original definition for the dot product
and the fact that we can get at the dot
product in two different ways we can get
at it by
comparing the angles and magnitudes of
the two vectors because that's what the
dot product tells you like oh how much
are they working together and against
with each other
or you can do it just by comparing the
components and we have proved why those
two results are the same so just to
refresh your memory that first
way of saying it is that
if you compare the magnitudes
and also the angle between them which is
in fact the thing that we want that
should be the same as looking at our
three different components so x1 and x2
the product y1 and y2 and then z1
z2 so i like to say i like to just go
back to that rather than have a cos
theta equals
some big fraction
also because i just find fractions
irritating to work with so i'm going to
say by the dot product
and i'm just going to write this result
that i've written in orange but for this
particular question right
so
what is the distance to a well it's
pythagoras so it's the square root of
2 squared plus 3 squared plus 5 squared
so last i checked that was 4 plus 9 plus
25 so there's the distance to a
here comes the distance to b so it's
going to be
5 squared plus 3 squared plus 7 squared
so that's 25 plus 9 plus 49
that's also all underneath the square
root because of pythagoras and then
there's the cos theta that's the part i
actually want and now i just have a look
at my x's and my y's and my z's and you
can see by the way i've sort of done a i
don't know if you noticed this but i did
a sneaky thing right i put these i laid
these out vertically so that my x's and
my y's and my z's would just line up
very neatly with each other so i can
just do the multiplication without even
thinking
so why didn't i use the colors since
i've done them right here comes the x's
two times five
and then i'm going to do the y's which
is uh minus three times three and then
i'm gonna do the z's which is what we
got here five times negative seven
okay when i have a think about what i've
got on the left hand side they're
slightly messy numbers that's okay it's
going to be the square root of that's
going to be
38 and then that's going to be 49 plus 9
is 58 so it's 83
there's the cos theta hanging out there
and then when you simplify all of that
let's see we've got 10 take away 9 take
away
35. and by the way you may say mr wu
just get out of calculator man and i
will get out of calculator in a second
but i'm just kind of trying to push my
brain for as much of this as i can
because the number of arithmetic errors
that crept into all of your solutions
indicates to me that your arithmetic
muscles have atrophied from lack of use
because you're like i have a calculator
i don't need to crunch these numbers but
you guys know a calculator will just
give you the answer to the question you
ask it you punch a single number wrong
put a bracket wrong forget to tap a
minus sign or press it too hard um you
know the answer will be wrong and you
won't even know it's wrong right so
that's why i'm pushing my brain to try
and do this calculation
uh let's see what do i get here so um 10
take away 9 is just negative it's just
positive 1 take away 35 is negative 34.
i'm going to divide by those gross
square roots over there on the right
hand side
and at this point i will reach for my
calculator you go ahead and you can work
this out i've already worked it out for
myself it's you end up simplifying this
to negative
0.6054 and some other stuff so that's
cos theta what i really want is theta
and of course one of the nice things
about cosine is that it will give us the
angle unambiguously so that's really
nice so that's
127.258 and some other
decimal places degrees thus the accuracy
that we were asked for was correct to
the nearest minute so again when you pop
that into your calculator hit the
degrees minute seconds button and you
should get 127 degrees and 15 minutes
and you should always say
how far you have approximated and there
you go